on était pas mal mais on dirait juste
pensé aux gens qu'ils appelent à vous
dire que personne n'ose après allez on
est à zapper qui me voient comme ça oui
vous avez une tata perruque à mai mais
tout me va mais alors là vous allez
pouvoir vous venger non la semaine
prochaine tant que julien doré par six
ingénieurs
j'adore je pense que vous faites bien
plaisir julien doré soir une question
bonjour je m'appelle jacques thing je
voudrais savoir qui est la personne la
plus méchante de l'équipe parce que j'ai
du mal à me faire une idée
vu que vous avez tous des cas de faux
culs
francis lui il s'intéresse vraiment à
l'équipe il dissèque tout ce qui se
passe un pendant les pubs pendant
l'émission tout ce qu'on voit pas
jean-luc l'on voit c'est difficile de
répondre à cette question en charge
l'accueil même si je pense que valérie
est une merde un allemand il ya peu de
méchanceté dans cette équipe
nous sommes une vraie famille et quand
nous avons des choses à dire nous le
disons en face à part peut-être tiré
moreau un masseur et d'infirmières
yapeng référent ma famille donc j'ai vu
les oppida c'est alors à vous et ce sera
beau témoignage vraiment très beau
témoignage me reste la bête donc vous
reste avec nous
et ça fait rire et la bac est tellement
gentille il est choqué france moi je
peux courir c'est un ventre a dit que je
lui dis plus tout pour séduire août
c'est pas un bon camarade je comprends
mieux pourquoi il a peur chaque semaine
avec les cats hier parce que je montre
son vrai visage
donc chaque jeudi pour thierry c'est
l'angoissé khatir ça va être chaud
moi ce n'est un salaire serait pas drôle
les gens sont mal ordures c'était pas
drôle d'accord car elles ont jamais fait
ce n'était pas drôle donc quitte à faire
pas drôle j'ai fait une petite copine de
toutes tes méchanceté à toi c'est bien
c'est que manitou jeune appelé le
méchant stocks
il parle de lui
on voit que t'es sortir a sorti j'étais
au restaurant les restos sympas génial
l'un deux heures au lit et en plus j'ai
pas il te reste au point leur ai dit
j'étais à des mutations de yoann stage
et étape à 8 et mesdames les clauses
dites nous ce que vous en pensiez un
déshabillé exceptionnel est alors mais
je rigolais créé ce qui se passait un
taux peut-être juste après non je tente
de mettre en avant ce qui me reste d'eau
potable la poitrine
ah bah je peux vous dire que je m'amuse
pas
d'une part accusé par l'odeur de paris
pense à rien je me moquais génie avec
toi est-ce qu'on va pas dire qu'on a un
peu on sème on est des frérots on
s'entraide
amitié c'est beau mais bon je vais pas
accabler jean-michel ce soir car il a
changé depuis un cyril annoncé en début
de semaine le nouveau jean michel est
arrivée un homme plus posé plus soucieux
de son image
il ya quinze jours nous recevions karine
le marchand et stéphane plaza laisser
reid avait annoncé au début d'émission à
caucourt de blague
bon comme 70% des annonces de cyril en
début d'émission nous ne l'avons pas
fait mais nous l'avions quand même
préparé et la prod avait réservé une
histoire jean michel qui ne
correspondait pas à son nouveau lui donc
là beaucoup choqué
non pas ça
basa est sympa non
un nom les gens qui n'ont pas si vichy
un malus mais nous non
là je change d'être trop chaud la voix
la défense je ne pas s'y lie sheehan
anus au bout la différence entre une
pastille mais chez anna luce le bon bout
le goût hasard
nouveau quinté + torreilles pour eux
cela n'a nullement la branche contrant
69 un chalet suisse
la vue
alors excusez lèvera à tanger des
manières excusez le ferons si vraiment
c'était plus correcte la deuxième set
bator et vous j'aime bien les deux
d'accord aussi où les huit ans j'aimais
bien les deux j'ai regardé deux autres
bien parce que la deuxième est d'accord
avec ça va il s'en fout ça écouler notre
question vaut bien là on s'est régalé
bonjour je m'appelle galiane je suis
très inquiète car cette semaine je n'ai
entendu personne dire du mal de cyril
hanouna est ce que ça veut dire que son
émission marche moins bien et non
schengen si personne n'a dit d'une
personne n'a dit du mal de cyril cette
semaine je pense que c'est simplement un
oubli qui sont à réparer dès la semaine
prochaine on l'espère pour elle je vous
rassure la cote de série n'a jamais été
aussi haute
bref je vous assure c'est flippant il
suffit de voir comment il a accueilli
par le public
même les gourous n'ont pas droit à ça
d'ailleurs je peux l'annoncer en voyant
l'extrait que je vais vous diffusez
cyril a décidé de lancer sa secte
londres de la sardine solaire
mais ça fait peur c'est bien ça fait
franchement c'est vrai que c'est assez à
ça ça en tête je suis heureux chante les
sardines motel 6 pc ca de mai pour se
débarrasser les noms mais il faut dire
que pour se faire aimer série love
chaque jour au public un plateau de
choix dans l'émission avec des invités
qui s'investissent comme ici garou qui
chantait en russe pour valérie bénaïm un
très beau moment as they both have to do
beau
j'avais dû dévier
les gens timides à droite du cul non il
faut savoir que jean-michel n'est pas
polyglotte mais c'est quand même dire
tomber dans 50 dollars alors niveau
happening toujours aussi créatif cyril
avait proposé aux chroniqueurs de manger
des rôles y ont cru bon heureusement il
a vite renoncé et a demandé au régisseur
de ramener les abats en coulisses ça
aurait pu finir comme ça mais non
alors beaucoup de gens horrifiés
toujours écrit pour comprendre le geste
de thierry pour savoir d'où je venais ce
sens du glamour j'ai la réponse
enfin thierry s'était acheté un joker
parce qu'il faut savoir s'il a l'air
gentil comme ça avec sa tête de
lémuriens des mûriers à regarder
le même cas c'est ça dont il a l'air
gentil comme ça mais c'est quand même un
patron cyril et pendant les pauses pub
quand un chroniqueur a fait une boulette
il vient lui parler mais c'est dans ces
moments là qu'un joker est utile
attention voici la phrase la plus
surréaliste de la coupe et j'ai mangé la
couille
l'autre touche enfin côté va jouer le
matin coup de coude l'eau des rejets
angéla couillon c'est vrai c'est vrai ça
fait que ses bottes
frasor contexte c'est bizarre mais il
faut s'attaquer à un barème très précis
si tu manges des écoutes hier trois
conneries dans l'émission il prélève pas
content tu vas voir une augmentation
rentrer dans l'équipe
oui travailler à touche pas à mon poste
c'est aussi renoncer à son amour propre
regardez de shérif ya trois ans était
fier et dit j'ai mangé la couille sa
sonde épitaphe
alors alors au début car il ya trois ans
il était fier et digne
trois ans plus tard alors qu'il découvre
le nouveau jeu que le dieu du paf a
soufflé cyril il est revenu de tout
regarder ce qui se passe si on a la
boule noire
image dégradante de routine fasse autre
chose car touche pas à mon poste c'est
aussi un moyen de survenue de tout ce
qui se fait à la télévision française et
surtout comprendre ce qui se fait tout
de suite le bachelor résumé en 8
secondes par cyril hanouna
je n'en fais pas ta rose t'as qu'à te la
[ __ ] je crois qu'on a bien compris le
pitch & touche pas à mon poste c'est
aussi des débats de fond
suite à un pari perdu c'est reed avait
promis de faire tout l'émission avec un
mini short en cuir comme jennifer lopez
on se souvient de sa alors c'était
rigolo mais c'était pas que rigolo
c'était également un excellent sujet
pour un moment de culture
est ce qu'on peut avoir trois là
l'expression
oh
une expression sache aucune tutelle
découlent j'irai pas choqué quand il ira
de faire l'âne c'est pas parce que tu
fais tu en sais pas ce que tu fais le
con je voulais vous régaler avec cette
séquence a que vous connaissiez jean
michel daire ou pas si vous le découvrez
seulement ce soir le nec
quand il a plus d'arguments je parle de
biologie on laisse parler la science
olala fort vous savez aussi certaines
mauvaises langues disent que notre
émission c'est un peu le café du
commerce
c'est faux mais j'ai voulu me rendre
compte de ce que ça serait si ça a été
vraiment le café du commerce
j'ai donc ralenti quelques images de
l'émission et vous allez voir plus clair
surtout quand c'est une démonstration
d'isabelle morini barre
il est libre elle envoie gilbert lui
l'être
j'ai pensé à rien fameux sous la halle
et à graulhet la veille souvent
imaginaires l'entraînement j'en ai vu
une petite partie n'en attend dès qu'un
gonflé ce que signifie sion changez-vous
derrier on ne retrouve pas les anglais
at-il rsa résume maintenant on veut
savoir quand même quand elle est une
longue honnêtement fou qui fait plutôt
bien travaillé et évidement qu'il
l'humour c'est la vitesse qui buzze
mexique il